là je commence à sentir quelque chose
parce que vraiment quand je reste ici
trop saoul trop longtemps et j'ai senti
la semaine dernière et des nausées
parce que ça ça pue et énormément vous
avez consulté un médecin
non pierre murat habite lapointe de
savane depuis des décennies il a vu
arriver les premières vagues de
sargasses en 2011
mais ils n'avaient encore jamais
ressenti physiquement leurs effets dans
ce quartier où les algues brunes se sont
échoués il ya quelques semaines ce n'est
pas un cas isolé
quand j'arrive ici sur son tour sordide
à l'école je prends l'eau d'heure et
après cette audience me donne des maux
de ventre et ensuite ça me donne des
maux de tête c'est qu'ils figurent et si
des fois au plus mal vous avez déjà
consulté un médecin par rapport à ces
problèmes
non pas vraiment ils sont consultation
pas de données fiables sur le nombre de
personnes concernées
le maire du robert compte donc sur ses
administrés pour fournir les certificats
médicaux et les déclarations de pertes
matérielles qui viendront étoffer le
dossier qu'il entend présenter au
gouvernement
vous avez des 4 ce n'est plus un rabot
le maire de l'ue et occasionnels c'est
quelque chose qu'aider à l'installer
donc il faut que l'état prenne une
disposition par rapport à elles sont
effectivement bien réelle les émanations
d'hydrogène sulfuré là où s'échouent les
sargasses l'association madininair les
mesures quotidiennement sur une
quinzaine de sites de la côte atlantique
il y a quelques jours un pic de
pollution étaient ainsi est constatée du
côté du françois
on a enregistré depuis donc la mise en
place la frégate est du capteur à
frégate est deux des dépassements de 2
ppm en micro en main par mètre cube en
journalier la semaine dernière d'une
exposition qui reste cependant bien en
deçà du seuil d'évacuation fixée par le
haut conseil de la santé publique à 5
microgrammes par mètre cube
quelques recommandations s'impose
néanmoins les personnes vulnérables les
femmes enceintes les jeunes enfants les
personnes sensibles c'est à dire ceux
qui ont déjà une pathologie
que ce soit du diabète que ce soit
d'hypertension ou autre si jamais ils
ont le moindre sentiment de gêne
il faut qu'ils consultent leurs leur
médecin les habitants du littoral sont
également invités à prendre chaque jour
connaissance des mesures effectuées
devant chez eux par madininair des
données consultable sur le site internet
de l'association